el calentamiento global ha llegado a uno
de los lugares recónditos del mundo a la
patagonia chilena a la apartada región
de aysén en la zona austral del país al
sur de esta región se ubica la zona de
campos de hielo considerada la tercera
masa glacial más extensa del planeta
tras la antártida y groenlandia según la
unidad de glaciología y nieves de chile-
la altura del glaciar ha disminuido 80
metros desde 1944 que podemos calcular
tasas de descenso y esas tasas a veces
nos dicen que el promedio en este
glaciar que se está descendiendo del
orden de 0 70 8 metros por año la
inmensa masa de hielo se podía ver hace
años a la media hora de entrar al parque
nacional laguna san rafael el más grande
de esta región hoy hay que caminar tres
horas para llegar al hielo chile poso de
la mayor superficie de glaciares de la
región está distribuido alrededor de 23
mil kilómetros cuadrados de hielo
de
sudamérica
los expertos chilenos explican que el
retroceso en los glaciares se debe a una
única causa a diferencia de otros
lugares en el mundo donde el carbono
negro u hollín o el polvo industrial
provocan el deshielo efecto del cambio
climático en forma más pura porque es
solo el efecto del calentamiento y no el
efecto de la contaminación por otra
fuente antropogénica los expertos
señalan también que el deshielo agravará
la sequía que vive chile desde hace más
de 13 años ya que estas reservas de agua
nutren los ecosistemas